hey leute und willkommen zu dem sechsten
video was ich heute schon hoch lade ich
weiß heute ist wieder so ein video
marathon welt wieder viel zu sagen
gesetzt habe ich hier gerade diesen
höhen zu und gehört und was jetzt
wahrscheinlich auch schon hört ist da
ich habe mein roter enthält sein endlich
zurück dass sie jetzt das erste video
was ich wieder damit aufgenommen habe
ich hoffe man hat die tastatur jetzt
nicht mehr so laut beziehungsweise gar
nicht mehr meine stimme hat sich nun
auch denke ich deutlich besser an ich
habe mir mal ein bisschen mehr zeit naja
was heißt müssen wir zeit ich hab halt
hier so ein paar sachen aufgebaut ihr
seht ja schon und zwar ist es das neue
update 12 w 21 b heißt das glaube ich
so müsste es eigentlich heißen und zwar
das erste ist ihr seht ich bin im
creative mode aber da man hat jetzt hier
kategorien habe ich sie getauft ich weiß
nicht wie es genau heißt aber man hat
hier zum beispiel diese building blocks
hier hat man so naturelle sachen oder
halt dekoration die wie ihr seht das
wohl alles noch nicht übersetzt die
redstone ist hier noch nicht übersetzt
hier zum beispiel redstone lampe
transport sachen also mein cards
schienen hier die ganze sache mit spot
des motion sowas mögliche ihr halt alles
zu essen hier hat man so tools wie zb
spitzhacken groß und so was alle sie hat
man sogar in sachen zum kämpfen ich
finde hier hat der lava auch noch
gefehlt oder ein feuerzeug na ja die hat
man dann flaschen und diese ganzen
browser aachen hier hat man materialien
wie zum beispiel pferde pulver diamanten
gold so was alles ja und hier unten hat
man das survival inventory ich bin mir
nicht noch nicht ganz so sicher was das
so wirklich bringt ich glaube man könnte
jetzt hier von da so einen blog rein und
dann könnte man so rumlaufen und wenn
man dann wirst du dass dir ach so ganz
normal die sache okay aber dann wenn man
dann so rumläuft und dann ist man ihn
wieder hinten oder so und euro falsche
taste dann kann man jeder wieder
reingehen hier zu sagen und dann kann
man sich die sachen raus in dem quasi so
sachen speichern sage ich mal und die
kann man dann so dann einfach wieder
daraus ziehen also dafür ist dass
zweifel in der theorie ganz gut und hier
oben ist der punkt search items den kann
man einerseits aufrufen zum beispiel
erdrückenden service dann könnt ihr zum
beispiel wort suchen dann habt ihr hier
alle möglichen sachen die mit wurz zu
tun haben oder ihr könnt werk suchen
dann habt ihr die werkbank zum beispiel
das ist dann wer von schwert wisst ihr
das heißt wer dann kommt das oder ihr
könnt dann zum beispiel auch einfach
wert eingeben dann kommt das auf das
finde ich ganz cool und ihr schließt das
inventory dann einfach mit estate und
wenn ihr so einfach suchen wollte so
könnt ihr dann einfach auch einfach so
ein geben die haben zum beispiel das
finde ich ganz cool da wird dann jeder
rohr also der erz angezeigt und die
haben einen blog dann alle items davon
und dann die sachen mit dem man sich
ausrüster mit denen man sich ausrüsten
kann also das erstmal zu den kategorien
dann was sich viele gewünscht haben und
was ich auch nicht hingekriegt habe in
den zwölf b21 update ist diese sachen
hiermit workbench hinzukriegen
allerdings wurde das jetzt endlich
gefixt und zwar macht man das einfach so
dass man die so macht die quasi normale
treppen und dann kriegt man da auch vier
stück ganz einfach raus die kann man
dann jetzt hier einfach irgendwo in der
pampa platzieren ist ganz schön und ich
bin gerade in versmold von daher habe
ich unendlich teile davon das ist ganz
schön dekorieren wir das hier mal des
wehrs melonen trend mit das wäre falsch
das wäre cool naja ist auch ganz schön
so also wir könnten doch aber
theoretisch ist
es so ich glaube dass ich jetzt nicht so
gut das sieht jetzt nicht mehr so toll
aus aber dann so die schweiz mal wieder
weg weil die sind wichtig und was nicht
auch noch sagen wollte dieser smaragd
heißt nun auch endlich emerald also
smaragd und den könnte hier oben jetzt
auch unter anderen suchen ich weiß nicht
und das macht es noch nicht weil er noch
keine deutsche besetzung kommt richtig
aber er heißt halt nicht mehr die haben
uns das nicht ganz cool findet und was
auch noch passiert ist das kann ich euch
so eben zeigen game watch zweifel ich
weiß nicht ob das schon länger dabei ist
aber das wollte jetzt auch auf deutsch
übersetzt täter ein spielmodus wurde
geändert und wenn ich dann zum beispiel
hier so einen abfahrer einfach diesen
sachen ich habe hier im provisorisch mal
so eine höhle auf
hingesetzt also wenn man sich das thema
von der seite als dieser das ist höchst
professionell eine höhle von con kräfte
aufgebaut dann bekommt ihr da diese
sachen raus und diese textur der blöcke
update schon wir sehen die gar grün
früher war die rot und jetzt sind die
teile hier auch die textur hat sich dann
ein wenig verändert und halt dass die
blöcke sicht auch sein alltag so und
außerdem dafür muss ich mal eben wieder
in den creative mode
so
der goldene boden sagt das ist so schön
hier gibt es einmal den normalen
goldenen apfel und jetzt diesen neuen
goldenen apfel also wenn ihr den dann
erst
gehen wir zurück
wenn ich den jetzt fest dann habt ihr
halt die hier diese neuen sachen also
das inventory verschiebt sich dann auch
nach rechts das ist ganz cool geworden
und man kann den jetzt auch so in
creative lothringen das halt früher
nicht wahr des weiteren gab es wieder
ein paar ganz normale kleine änderungen
paar bugfixes aus 12 21 a wie zum
beispiel das jetzt in ein paar wenigen
dörfern nicht mehr diese schwarzen teile
manchmal auftreten und der klient also
der download ist ja immer und mit der
beschreibung der läuft nun auch ohne die
server datei davon früher war das so
also das heißt früher beim 12 23
arbeiter so dass man dafür immer noch
eine server nicht auf eine sms bekommt
dass man dafür immer noch eine server
datei benötigte die braucht man nun
nicht mehr einfach die datei downloaden
die ich euch in die beschreibung packe
und dann könnt ihr damit quasi spielen
also jetzt wie immer treffe in die
kommentare was ihr von den neuen
änderungen hier an grenzen versetzt das
crafting rezept war oder ob sie den
neuen kategorien diese neu
ob oder ob jetzt diese diese neuen
kategorien hier waren also ich finde die
kategorien ja mal and geil das ist echt
die bildaussage schon so ich würde mich
auf jeden fall über den daumen hoch
freuen wäre ganz gut wenn wegen die 400
daumen hoch schaffen würden manchmal
wieder so eine kleine challenge wenn ihr
das schafft seit ihr mega cool für sechs
videos am tag nein spaß und ich würde
mich über den daumen hoch freundin ist
aber kein muss und schreiben wir das in
die kommentare was ihm gefahndet wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal